The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Welcome, everybody,
on this snowy Friday.
At the end of last hour,
and I just want to take a
minute or two here to finish
this piece up,
we were talking about ways of
writing kinetics expressions for
a particular type of assumed
ligand substitution mechanism.
In particular,
we were looking at dissociative
substitution.
And now I would just like to
take you through what happens if
you don't make the major
assumption that we made last
time, which was that every time
our intermediate five coordinate
complex ML five was
formed, it would go onto
products.
That was our assumption last
time, one of them.
And this steady state
approximation is one that allows
us to simplify the rate
expression.
If we don't make that
assumption, what we say is that
the change with time of the
concentration of the
intermediate is approximately
zero.
We know that at the very
beginning of the reaction,
we have this ML five X
species.
X is the ligand that
dissociates to give ML five,
so at time zero there
is zero ML five
concentration.
And let me just remind you of
this plot of what happens in a
reaction like this.
We have our initial ML five X
species that decays
away, and we have our product ML
five Y that grows in.
And if this reaction goes by
dissociative ligand
substitution,
which would certainly be
consistent with a d four
high spin electron count,
as we saw last time,
then there may be some
intermediate ML five
that at time zero has zero
concentration.
And it may never really build
up very much concentration.
And then at the end,
it goes down to zero,
too, because when the reaction
is over, all of our ML five has
a Y attached and is
six-coordinate again.
If the concentration of the ML
five intermediate never
really builds up very much,
which is quite often the case,
it may not be observable,
the amount of which is produced
during the reaction,
then this approximation is
pretty valid and allows us to
derive equations for the change
with time of the species that we
can observe, namely the starting
material that is going away and
the product that is coming in.
And so this is our
concentration versus time plot
for the reaction.
And with this approximation,
we can then set equal to zero
the expression for the formation
of the intermediate,
which is k1 times ML five X.
This quantity k1,
if you remember back to the
diagram we were using last time,
k1 is the rate constant
associated with surmounting that
first energy barrier,
k1 times ML five X.
That produces ML five,
so this is producing
it, but when you are in the
middle of the well,
where the intermediate lies,
there are two ways to destroy
ML five.
You can go minus k minus one ML
five times X.
This brings you,
then, back over to where you
started.
And you can also lose it in a
productive sense by k two times
ML five times our species Y,
which brings us onto products.
And we are still making the
assumption that once you get to
products, the reaction is done
and you never go back.
That assumption is built into
this analysis.
And if we look at this,
we have set it equal to zero,
meaning that ML five is
not building up.
And so now, what we can do is
we can rearrange this expression
and solve it for the
concentration of ML five.
And you will see that you can
do that here.
ML five becomes equal to k1
times ML five X --
That is the expression for the
formation.
These two brackets should be
done.
ML five X over k minus one
times Y plus.
Sorry.
That should be X,
here.
Plus k2, times Y.
The expression
in the denominator here are
those two quantities that take
us out of the well.
And on the top,
we have the one quantity that
takes us into the well from the
starting materials.
And so now, we have an
expression for ML five
that we can plug into our
expression for the rate.
The rate overall expressed as
the appearance of the final
product is going to be equal to
k2 times ML five,
this is going over the final
barrier, times Y.
And so,
if we take the expression here
for the rate,
this is the value that we
expect for the appearance of
products.
We take that substitute in this
expression for the unobserved
intermediate,
ML five,
into this.
Then we have an expression for
the rate entirely in terms of
things that we can either
observe, namely the starting
material, the concentration we
would measure by some technique,
like spectrophotometry as a
function of time,
watching an absorbance band for
it decay away,
for example.
And then also in terms of the
concentration of Y which we were
talking about as the solvent,
so it would have a large
invariant and known
concentration.
And then, of course,
since X is being produced in
the reaction whenever it
dissociates from the starting
material, there is a
relationship between the
concentration of X at any time
and the concentration of our
starting material at any time.
Now we get an expression that
we need to be able to integrate
in order to actually produce,
given these parameters,
k1, k minus 1,
and k2, to produce a predicted
dataset to compare with the
experimental.
And what one normally does is
you take an experimental
dataset, you have the equations
that arise from your mechanistic
hypothesis, and you do a least
squares fitting procedure to
obtain the values of the
parameters, which are these
phenomenological rate constants
associated with each step in the
mechanism.
Extract the values of the
parameters, and see what you
get, see if the mechanism that
you have assumed can give you a
good fit to the data or whether
it cannot.
That is the end of my
discussion of an introduction to
kinetic analysis of chemical
reactions, a really important
subject where differential
equations really become very
important.
Today, I want to get onto the
top of extended solids,
and so I am going to talk about
dimensionality,
here.
And materials.
And I want you to keep in mind
the framework with which we have
been discussing chemical bonding
all throughout this semester
because we are going to extend
that today to try to understand
some of the properties of
systems that are not molecular,
but extend infinity in some
number of dimensions.
We talked about the H two
molecule.
This is a very small molecular
system that we have described
and talked about quite a bit.
This system has a radius,
here, of about 0.64 angstroms,
or internuclear distance of
about 0.64 angstroms.
And then, we can also consider
molecules that become more
extended.
There is an example of a
polyene.
And my use of a polyene,
here, should lead you to think
that when we consider polymer
chemistry, in some cases,
we will be talking about
systems that are extended,
maybe not infinitely,
but very greatly in one
direction, or maybe more than
one direction.
But polyenes are interesting
species because if this thing
had all the double bonds,
trans, as I have drawn here,
then what we have perpendicular
to the board would be a set of p
orbitals, one p orbital
perpendicular to the board on
each of these carbons.
And all of those p orbitals can
overlap.
And then, we can start talking
about the transport of electrons
down a chain like this in one
dimension.
So I put H two up here
as an example of what is
approximately a zero dimensional
system.
Here is a system that extends
somewhat in one dimension.
And then, as an example of a
two dimensional system,
let me just draw up here a
piece of one of the sheets of
the graphite structure.
Graphite is one of the
allotropes of carbon.
And graphite is a really nice
2d structure.
I can draw in some of the
unsaturation here.
And I don't mean to suggest
that this thing stops here.
These carbons on the parameter
of the graphite system have
bonds, and the structure looks
very much like what I have drawn
here, if you repeat outward,
up, down, left,
or right.
And what that leads to are
two-dimensional planar arrays of
carbon atoms that,
as with the polyene structure,
here this polyene that I drew
with six bonds,
is about 13 angstroms long.
And then the problem that you
get to with graphite is that
these graphite sheets can have
dimensions of millimeters.
You have gone from something
short to something very,
very large.
And we are going infinitely.
I am going to show you a little
bit more about this.
I am going to let you look at
this website yourselves.
You are going to find that I
did put into the notes for today
the website that we are going to
look at.
And it is for you to go ahead
and look at in three-dimensions
at the structure of the
graphite.
And also, in particular,
I want you to be able to look
at the structure of the diamond
framework.
One of the things that I want
you to be thinking about in
association with today's lecture
are the way that atoms pack in
three dimensions when you make
up a solid material.
You will see why that is
important in just a moment.
And so we are going to have to
go from bonds to bands in order
to make this transition.
And that means we are going to
have to talk about band
structure today and where bands
come from.
This, by the way,
the title for this panel from
bonds to bands is actually the
inverse of a title that was
penned for a beautiful article
written by Professor Roald
Hoffmann.
And he was actually one of my
teachers as an undergraduate at
Cornell University,
and he also won the Nobel Prize
for his contributions to theory.
And I refer you to his article
from bands to bonds if you want
to learn more about this topic
because, although the concepts
of solid state physics are often
discussed with very different
terminology than the concepts of
electronic structure theory for
molecules, there are a lot of
very important parallelisms.
And one of the things that
Professor Hoffmann is very good
at is in bridging the gap
between different branches of
science that talk about the same
things but don't realize that
they are talking about the same
things.
And so here we have a system
with a single orbital.
We are going to look at the
number of orbitals.
And here is a system with one.
And this is an energy level
diagram.
We have used energy level
diagrams for a lot of things.
Last lecture,
we used them to discuss
potential energy surfaces of
chemical reactions,
in addition to all these other
properties.
Here is a system with one
orbital.
And then, as you know,
when you have a system with two
orbitals, you can get bonding
and antibonding.
This is the hydrogen problem.
This might be a hydrogen atom,
for example.
Here is an H two
molecular orbital diagram.
And then we can consider a
system that might have three
orbitals populated,
like this.
And then, if we have a system
with four orbitals,
it might be something like
that, four electrons and so on.
We see that one of the features
is that the energy levels are
starting to come closer together
as we get more and more of them.
There are five.
Here is six.
And then, onto seven.
And you start running out of
room to draw them.
And so, what people do then
with this problem,
we are only up to seven and we
have almost run out of space to
draw these things.
So what do we do?
We draw them,
when we get out to infinity
here, as a band.
What the idea is,
is that we have here this band
diagram, as we are going to call
them, a type of diagram in which
we are representing field
orbitals down here as some kind
of continuum.
Because there are so many of
them, an infinite number of
orbitals that are all
interacting in some extended
solid material,
we are going to be talking
today a little bit about silicon
and germanium and things like
gallium nitride,
in which you have a lattice
that extends periodically in
three-dimensions.
And so these molecular orbitals
spread out and cover the whole
material.
Electrons can be anywhere at
once within this entire extended
solid by virtue of these
delocalized orbitals.
And then, just like in
molecules, there are empty
orbitals.
And they occur,
also, in a continuum.
I would like you to get your
mind around going from both ends
to the same place in that type
of continuum.
And the idea that these band
structure diagrams that people
use to describe the electronic
structure properties of extended
materials are really molecular
orbital diagrams.
And so let's take a typical
metal, where n equals three,
principle quantum number three.
The atom has a 1s orbital.
It has a 2s and a set of 2p
orbitals.
It has a 3s orbital and a set
of 3p.
And so there is an atom,
like a sodium atom,
for example.
And here is our energy axis.
What happens is that each of
these orbitals,
that when you put all these
atoms together into a piece of
solid sodium metal,
we talked about that earlier in
the semester,
these orbitals overlap,
spread out and form bands.
And there is a band very low in
energy that is derived from the
1s electrons in a metal like
sodium.
And it is completely full.
And then there is a band from
the 2s and there is a band,
accordingly,
from the 2p.
And then there will be a band
from the 3s, and a band from the
3p that I have run out of room
to draw there.
And notice that the bands that
originate from atomic orbitals
having the same principle
quantum number here,
2s and 2p, are overlapping.
In the case of a sodium atom,
this 2s band is completely full
with electrons and the 2p band
is completely full.
And this 3s band here,
in the case of sodium,
is half full.
Furthermore,
we are going to call these
filled bands that are at the
highest energy.
This corresponds to our highest
occupied molecular orbital.
That will be called the valance
band.
And then up here,
the lowest unoccupied band is
called the conduction band.
And so, in the case of sodium
metal, this 3s band is half
full.
And, if we go over to
magnesium, this same 3s band is
now full.
And if we go to aluminum,
that 3s band is full,
and the 3p band is partly full.
And it is a consequence of the
fact that the electrons in the
valance band are right here at
the same energy as the lowest
part of the conduction band in a
metal that gives metals their
luster.
It gives them their 100%
optical reflectivity,
--
-- these properties that we
very much associate with metals.
And so from analyzing band
structure diagrams,
even simplified ones,
like the ones you will find
here and in your textbook today,
you can really say a lot about
the properties of different
materials.
When you have a meeting of the
valance band and the conduction
band, then your material is a
conductor and is metallic.
And then, there are other
possibilities,
of course.
You may have a valance band
that is separated by some energy
gap from the conduction band.
And if that is that is the
case, then you have a
semi-conductor,
such as silicon.
And then, finally,
you can have a large gap
between your valance band and
your conduction band.
And, in all cases,
like with an MO diagram,
we are putting these things on
an energy axis.
We are filling up electrons
from the bottom in this material
from the standpoint of energy,
and so you have a large gap,
here.
And you have a material that is
an insulator.
And I think you will appreciate
why that is in a moment,
but I want to bring Boltzmann's
law to bear on the issue of
electronic structure in extended
networks, like we are talking
about today.
In materials like the ones I
have drawn over here,
the ability to conduct
electricity is related to the
probability of electrons being
in the conduction band.
So we need to know something
about electrons in the
conduction band.
And, using a Boltzmann
distribution,
we can write that probability
as being related to one over (e
to the (delta E over RT)) plus
one.
And, with an expression like
this, this delta E here
corresponds to our gap.
And so it is possible,
then, to go ahead and estimate
the number of electrons that
would be present in a cubic
centimeter of your material in
the condition band as a function
of this energy gap.
And so we can consider that for
materials like carbon or silicon
or elemental germanium.
In the case of carbon,
I am talking about diamond.
And you should definitely go to
that specified website and look
at the diamond structure and try
to get an appreciation for how
the carbon atoms in diamond pack
in three dimensions.
From a hybridization
standpoint, all the carbons in
graphite are sp two.
Whereas, in diamond all the
carbons are sp three
and tetrahedral.
And completing this table,
--
-- we can write down delta E in
kilojoules per mole.
The gap for diamond is
kilojoules per mole,
for silicon,
117 kilojoules per mole,
and for germanium,
66 kilojoules per mole.
And here is the number of
electrons per centimeter cubed
in the material in the
conduction band.
And, based on this large energy
gap in the diamond structure,
this value is on the order of
10^-27.
Very small.
This is an insulator.
Diamond is an insulator.
And, on the other hand,
silicon, the number of
electrons per cubic centimeter
that are in the conduction band
are on the order of 10^9.
This much smaller gap in the
case of silicon,
despite the fact that the
silicon atoms also are
tetrahedrally disposed with
respect to their bonding,
just as in the diamond case,
we have a much smaller gap,
10^9.
And that makes silicon,
as you know,
a semiconductor.
And then germanium,
10^13, so even more.
It is getting closer and closer
to being metallic as the gap
shrinks as we compare these
materials.
And, having said that,
we need to talk about the
different types of materials
that we can have.
I want you to understand the
difference between intrinsic and
extrinsic semiconductors.
If a semiconductor material is
an intrinsic semiconductor,
that means that it is a
semiconductor in its pure state.
And why would we make that
reference?
I mean normally,
we are always talking about
pure things.
But, actually,
you will see in a moment that
people do purposely make impure
semiconductors for very good
reasons.
And we will discuss
semiconductor when pure.
And what that means is you have
a system like this with some
kind of a small band gap,
as we have suggested.
Here is our energy axis.
And what can happen is that,
either thermally or upon
absorption of light energy,
we can have promotion of an
electron from the valance band
into the conduction band.
And so I will draw that new
situation over here.
In other words,
we may have thermal population
of our conduction band.
And we generate,
accordingly,
a hole.
In this intrinsic
semiconductor,
for every electron that jumps
up into the conduction band and
can then provide conductivity by
electron transport --
Down here, in the valance band,
the missing electron generates
a hole.
And that hole can move around
freely in the valance band.
How does it do that?
Well, it is a little bit like
the mechanism that we studied
earlier for translocation of
protons in acidic water.
If an electron that is nearby
the hole jumps into the hole,
it creates another hole.
The hole thereby moves.
And so here,
we can have hole transport in
our valance band.
You can have conductivity
occurring freely both in the
valance band and in the
conduction band for an intrinsic
semiconductor of this type,
where the number of holes is
equal to the number of
electrons.
And you might begin to suspect
that for an extrinsic
semiconductor,
the number of holes does not
equal the number of electrons.
How does that work?
In these extrinsic
semiconductors wherein you have
differing numbers of holes and
electrons, you are purposely
adding a small percentage of
impurities to your material.
Let me draw two pictures to
represent this.
Here, I would like to draw just
a simple tetrahedron.
We are looking at a very small
part of the silicon structure.
Let me put the silicons in here
in color.
Each silicon is coordinated to
four other silicons in elemental
silicon.
It is tetrahedral silicon all
through this three-dimensional
material in which these bands
have been created,
and in which we have valance
and conduction bands.
But what if we have synthesized
our silicon with a little bit of
boron impurity?
If we do that,
then boron goes into a position
in the crystal lattice that is
normally occupied by silicon,
so boron finds itself
surrounded by four silicons,
each of which wishes to donate
an electron to the boron to form
an electron pair bond.
But boron only has three of the
needed four electrons to make
those four two-electron bonds
and to generate the octet.
And so what happens is it wants
to get an electron.
And where can it get an
electron from?
It can get an electron from the
valance band,
from the HOMO of the system,
from what would be able to
donate an electron in the
system.
The way this then works is as
follows.
You should think about the
structure of elemental silicon
with a small number of boron
atoms dispersed throughout that
structure as creating localized
negative charges that cannot
move because they are localized
on these borons.
And that generates for you a
band structure diagram like
this.
You have bands,
but then you have slipped in
there a little orbital from the
boron, a little electronic state
here, an intermediate between
the valance band and the
conduction band.
So you have to choose your
impurity correctly,
so that it has the right energy
with respect to the valance band
and the conduction band in order
for the process that you want to
occur.
Here is our boron-derived
state, here, and it needs that
extra electron because it is
electron deficient when you put
it in there.
And so an electron jumps onto
the boron, we will represent
that this way,
in the material like that.
And this electron is fixed in
position --
-- because it is associated
with a negative charge that has
formed on the boron.
And a corresponding hole is
formed down in the conduction
band, and this hole transport
can give rise to conductivity.
And so notice that in this type
of semiconductor,
and this, by the way,
is a p-type semiconductor.
P for positive.
You are putting in a hole on
that boron, so this is a p-type
of semiconductor.
This thing is stuck on the
boron, and it generates a hole
that is free to move in the
valance band and give rise to
conductivity.
And so in this extrinsic-type
of semiconductor,
you are not necessarily getting
any conductivity up here in the
normal conduction band but down
in the valance band due to the
creation of the hole.
And then the parallel situation
to that would be where you have
something that you dope into the
structure that has one more
electron than what is normally
in the structure.
Normally, you are putting in
silicon atoms each of which has
four valance electrons.
You put in a phosphorus atom,
which isn't nearly the same
size as silicon,
but has five valance electrons.
So you have this phosphorus in
here, and it is tetrahedrally
coordinated to four silicons.
And there is only a few
percentage of phosphorous atoms
doped into this silicon
semiconductor.
And the phosphorus,
what happens is it goes in
there.
It has an extra electron.
It wants to give it up so that
it can have just an octet and
form these four bonds to the
four silicons.
And when it gives up that
electron, the electron goes out
and that forms a positive charge
that is localized and fixed on
the phosphorous center in the
structure.
And so, we can represent that
as follows.
Where we have a phosphorus
state that we had chosen
appropriately in energy to go
ahead and give up that electron,
it gives up the electron to the
lowest unoccupied orbitals in
the system, which is the bottom
part of your conduction band.
This electron jumps up off the
phosphorus and into the
conduction band,
and that leaves behind a hole.
So you have a hole or a
positive charge,
there, fixed in position.
And now you can have electron
transport as your mechanism of
conductivity,
up in the conduction band.
It is really,
I think, quite fascinating to
think about the way in which the
concept of the octet rule and
our understanding of bonding in
tetrahedral centers can actually
lead us to understand the
mechanism of conductivity in
solid materials that are either
n-doped or p-doped.
Here, it is quite clear.
And then, finally,
I just want to take you through
the way in which you can put the
positive and negative doped
materials together to create a
device like a light-emitting
diode.
LED materials,
these are obviously great
things because you can generate
light with a lot more efficiency
in terms of energy than you can
with incandescent bulbs.
You can get them in all
different colors.
These are finding application
in so many different ways.
One of the challenges that
chemists have taken on is the
discovery of light-emitting
diode materials that are made of
organic molecules,
actually, conducting organic
molecules that have properties
correct for giving you very
narrow emissions in the part of
the spectrum that you want to
have coming out of your
light-emitting diode material.
So chemistry is really very
strongly involved in making
next-generation LED materials.
But I just want to tell you a
little bit about how these
things work.
The idea is that you have these
two types of semiconductors,
and you juxtapose them at an
interface.
Let me make the interface with
blue.
You have a solid chunk of
material, here.
This will be our N-type
semiconductor.
And over here,
they have a continuous,
possibly two dimensional
interface here in this
three-dimensional chunk of
material.
And you have a P-type doped
part of the system over here.
And, in fact,
normally this would be the same
basic semiconductor material on
both sides of the interface.
And it would be just the doping
that changes on the left versus
the right.
This material might be
something like gallium nitride.
Now, notice that this is a 3/5
type of material.
And this is gallium in Group 13
and nitrogen in Group 15 of the
Periodic Table.
You add three and five together
and you get eight,
just the same number of valance
electrons you would if you had
silicon and silicon.
But these materials have the
property that they are a direct
band gap material.
And, as direct band gap
materials, when the process that
we are going to talk about here
takes place at the interface,
then out of this interface
comes the light.
And if your semiconductor
material is an indirect band gap
material like silicone is,
then that is not the case.
And that has to do with the
solid state physics of
electronically,
where is the conduction band
located relative to that valance
band?
Has it shifted horizontally in
solid physics-speak relative to
the valance band?
That's what makes a
semiconductor an indirect band
gap material.
If the conduction band is
vertically situated above the
valance band,
then you get a direct band
material.
And so solid state chemists are
interested in designing new
materials that have a direct
band gap and that can release
light when this process takes
place at the interface.
And on both sides,
I just want to sketch the band
structure for the materials.
And I mean the gap,
actually, to be the same on
both sides here.
And the difference is what we
have doped it with.
In the case of the negative
material, we have an electron up
here in the conduction band that
came in with,
for example,
our phosphorus atom and left
behind a hole there that is
fixed in space.
And down here we have our
valance band all full.
Over here similar,
except our material starts out
with a hole down there because
the electron has jumped up onto
the doped atom and become fixed
in space as a negative charge.
And that left behind a hole in
the valance band down there like
that.
What you have is your N-doped
material here on the left,
your P-doped material on the
right.
And, of course,
what do you do then?
You attach leads so that you
can connect it to a potential
difference.
And, when you do that,
you want your anode to be over
here, so that the electrons can
flow that way up to the N part
of the device.
And then electrons can flow
this way, which means,
of course, that holes go that
way.
And here is your cathode.
And so you can think of putting
on your potential difference in
a system like this.
And that has the effect of
ripping electrons out over here.
And, if you rip an electron
out, let's say you take that
negative charge back off of that
boron atom, you pull an electron
out to go ahead and reduce
something down here in solution,
if you are using a battery for
this sort of process,
well, then another electron can
jump up here to take its place.
But you are building up a
potential, here.
And so, what happens?
The highest lying electron in
the system over here in the
N-type semiconductor is sitting
there right at the junction
right next to where electrons
are needed.
It jumps across.
Electrons flow downhill,
here.
And you can look at it like
this, electrons flow down there,
across the interface.
And when you hook this LED up
to your potential difference
supply, the electron flow is
unidirectional.
As the electrons jump across
the interface,
they are going from the
conduction band of the N-type
semiconductor,
they are going down in here,
holes are being created,
maybe electrons are being
pulled right off of that boron,
and they are moving right
across here in a process that
leads to the emission of light
right at the interface.
It is like a waterfall of
electrons taking place all along
this 2D interface.
Electrons are just moving
across this interface and
dropping down in energy.
As they drop down in energy,
a photon that is the energy of
this energy difference between
the gap of this material,
those photons are released for
each electron that transits this
barrier.
And that is the principle of an
LED.
And I hope you are enjoying
seeing this connection between
molecular orbital theory for
molecules being taken all the
way to solid state physics.
Have a nice weekend and we will
see you on Monday.